[Music]
on this vote the yeas are 265
the nays are 124 two thirds bringing the
affirmative the real service fest
suspended the bill is passed without
objection the motion reconsiders laid on
the table
pursuant to clause state of route 20 the
unfinished business on the question
on agreeing to the motion to recommit on
h.r
3884 offered by the gentlewoman of
arizona mr let's go
on which the yeas were ordered the clerk
will redesignate the motion
motion to recommit on h.r 3884 offered
by mrs lesko of arizona
the question is an agreement on the
motion recommit members will record
their votes by
electronic device
development from arizona seek
recognition
as a member as the member designated by
ms kirkpatrick pursuant to hres 965 i
informed the house that mr patrick will
vote no
on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mr grijalva
will vote no on the motion to recommit
[Music]
oh
for what purpose does the gentleman from
washington seek recognition
as the member designated by dr schreier
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that dr schreier will vote no
on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr schneider
of illinois pursuant to house res 965
i inform the house that mr schneider
will vote no on the motion to recommit
daytime
[Music]
they're all excited
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
thank you madam speaker as a member
designated by mr
doyle of pennsylvania pursuant to house
resolution 965. i hereby inform the
house
mr doyle will vote no on the motion to
recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
good morning madam speaker as the member
designated by the honorable mr james
langevin of rhode island
pursuant to house resolution 965 i'd
like to inform the house that mr
langevin will vote no
on the motion to recommit h.r 388 for
the more act of 2020. thank you
oh
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from florida seek recognition
madam speaker as the member designated
by ms mukhersel powell of florida
pursuant to hres 965.
i informed the house that ms mugasel
powell will vote nay on the motion to
recommit
madam speaker is the member designated
by mr hastings of florida pursuant to
hres 965. i inform the house that mr
hastings will also vote nay
on the motion to recommit and madam
speaker as the member designated by mr
payne of new jersey pursuant to hres
965. i
inform the house that mr payne will also
vote nay on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from illinois seek recognition as the
member designated by mr rush pursuant to
hres 965 i inform the house that mr rush
will vote no
on the motion to recommit
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from new hampshire seek recognition
madam speaker as the member designated
by ms pingree pursuant to adress 965
i inform the house that ms pingree will
vote
no on the motion to recommit as the
member designated by ms lee
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
that ms lee
will vote no on the motion to recommit
as the member designated by mr kennedy
pursuant to h
965 i inform the house that mr kennedy
will vote
no on the motion to recommit and as the
member designated by ms mang
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that ms mang
will vote no on the motion to recommit
from california seek recognition madam
speaker as the member designated by
brian
higgins from new york pursuant to atres
965
i inform the house that mr higgins will
vote nay on the motion to recommit
this is a gentleman from massachusetts
recognition
as a member designated by mr welsh of
vermont pursuant to hres 965 i will
inform the house that mr welsh will vote
no on the motion to recommit
what purpose does the gentleman from new
york seek recognition
madam speaker as the member designated
by representative loewy
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that representative loewy
will vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from florida seek recognition
as a member designated by mr lawson
pursuant to h.r
965 i informed the house that mr lawson
will vote no
on the motion to recommit as the member
designated by miss castor pursuant to
house resolution 965 i informed the
house that ms castor will vote
no on the motion to recommit
thank you
lynn from missouri seek recognition
madam speaker as a member designated by
andre carson pursuing 2h res hres965
i inform the house that mr carson will
vote no on the motion to recommit
thank you
the gentlewoman from michigan seek
recognition as the member designated by
dr loez of california pursuant to hres
965 i informed the house that dr
rose will vote no on the motion to
recommit
as the member designated by miss captor
of ohio pursuant to hres 965
i inform the house that miss captor will
vote
no on the motion to recommit
[Music]
for what purpose does a gentlewoman from
connecticut seek recognition
as the member designated by miss wilson
pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that miss wilson
will vote no on the motion to recommit
[Music]
for what purpose does a gentlewoman from
massachusetts seek recognition
madam speaker is the member designated
by ms frankel pursuing to hres 965.
i informed the house that ms frankel
will vote no
on the motion to recommit as the member
designated by ms bonamici pursuant to
hres
965 i inform the house that ms bonamici
will vote no
on the motion to recommit and as the
member designated by ms brownlee
pursuant to 965
house resolution 965 i informed the
house that ms brownlee will vote no
on the motion to recommit
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman for
virginia seek recognition
madam speaker is a member designated by
mr rooney pursuant to hs965
and from the house of mr rooney we'll
vote yes on the motion to recommit
as the member dedicated by mr liu
pursuant to his 965
inform the house of mr liu will vote no
on the motion to recommit
as the member is aided by ms baragon
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
ms baragon will vote no
on the motion to recommit as the member
designated by mr lowe with all pursuant
dangerous 965.
inform the house to mr lowenthal will
vote no on the motion to recommit
as the member designated by ms moore
pursuant to his 965
informative ms moore will vote no on the
motion to recommit
and as the member does it anyway mr
cohen of tennessee pursuant to his 965
and from the house mr cohen will vote no
on the motion to recommit
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
madam speakers member designated by
congress member napolitano
pursuant to house resolution 965.
i wish to inform the body that miss
napolitano will vote
no on the motion to recommit
tennessee for what
is the gentleman from tennessee sick
recognition thank you madam speaker as
the member designated by mr costa
pursuant to hres and i-65 i inform the
house and mr costa will vote no on the
motion to recommit
seek recognition as the member
designated by mr lipinski of illinois
pursuant to house raise 965.
i inform the house mrs lipinski will
vote yes on the motion recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
north carolina seek recognition
madam speaker is the member designated
by mr price of north carolina
restorative house rares 965 and inform
the house that mr price will vote no
will vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose is the gentleman from
california seek recognition
as the member designated by dr bera
pursuant to house resolution 965
i informed the house that dr vera votes
no on the motion to recommit
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah for what purpose does the
gentlewoman from new york seek
recognition
as the member designated by mr deutsch
of florida pursuant to hres eight
nine six five i informed the house that
mr deutsch will vote
no on the motion to recommit
videos
i know
thank you
yes
foreign
okay
for what purpose does a gentleman from
new york seek recognition
as a member dedic as a member designated
by a chairwoman anybody johnson pursuant
to hres 965 inform the house that
chairwoman johnson will vote no
on the motion to recommit as the member
designated by
chairwoman zoe lofgren pursuant to hps
965 on former house the chairwoman
lofgren
will vote no on the motion to recommit
it's the member designated by chairman
jerry nadler pursuant to hres 965 i
inform the house that chairman nadler
will vote no on the motion to recommit
is the member designated by
congressman jose serrano pursuant to hps
965 inform the house that congressman
serrano
will vote no on the motion to recommit
it's the member designated by
congressman brendan boyle
pursuant to hres 965 and inform the
house that congressman boyle
will vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
madam speaker as the member designated
by mr peters of california pursuant to
hres 965 i inform the house that mr
peters
will vote no on the motion to recommit
okay
this is
what's
god
okay everybody
future
[Music]
is
[Music]
mic check mic check one two three four
mic check this mic check mic check one
two three four
one two three four
so
so
so
which one is uh
are we good can everybody hear me
okay good morning everybody my name is
greg sofer
i'm the united states attorney for the
western district of texas
i want to thank you for being here with
us today
i'm going to introduce the other folks
who are behind me
we have stephen s whipple who's the drug
enforcement administration
houston division special agent in charge
we have richard d goss who's the
internal revenue service criminal
investigations
houston field office special agent in
charge we have jennifer stevenson
assistant chief with the austin police
department
we have todd radford the chief of the
lakeway police department
we have commander brian wutash of the
cedar park
police department and also up here are
assistant united states attorneys mark
marshall and robert almonte who was from
my office
i'm going to reach around here
this and a number of the other items
that are on this table are poison
worse yet many of the pills before you
are camouflaged as legitimate and
regulated prescription medication
when unsuspecting college kids and other
drug users put these pills
in their mouth they are playing russian
roulette
they are gambling that the drug dealers
did not place lethal doses of drugs like
methamphetamine
or fentanyl in these pills
tragically many times their gamble goes
horribly wrong
and they overdose and sometimes die
if they do survive they risk becoming
addicted to these highly toxic
and life-destroying drugs just as an
example
the long-term effects of meth on a human
body and brain
are nothing less than horrific
imagine your college student taking what
he or she thinks is prescription
adderall
or xanax and instead getting hooked
on methamphetamine or fentanyl
or some other dangerous opioid
this dangerous business must be stopped
today we're here to announce the arrest
and in federal indictment of 13
people including current and former
university texas students
for allegedly distributing and selling
among other things lsd
philosophical fentanyl and
methamphetamine pills to university of
texas students and others
both here and in san antonio
the federal grand jury indictment
unsealed today charges all 13 of these
individuals
with conspiracy distribute to distribute
a controlled substance
some of the defendants are also charged
with money laundering
these charges are the culmination of
operation spiderweb
which began in 2019 when federal state
and local law enforcement officers
noticed a disturbing increase
in the in the distribution of
counterfeit controlled substances
specifically lsd
adderall xanax oxycodone
and other pills in mustang area
law enforcement learned that thousands
of dosage units of these counterfeit
pills
were being distributed in and around the
west campus area
here in austin and noticed a
corresponding increase
in overdose reporting
make no mistake about it these are not
pills being carefully manufactured and
tested
by sophisticated pharmaceutical
companies
in fact two targets of this
investigation overdosed and died
during the course of the investigation
investigators discovered that 23 year
old varun prasad of austin
was the leader of a distribution network
that sold
mdma lsd philosophical which is also
known as hallucinogenic
counterfeit adderall counterfeit xanax
and other drugs on a wholesale and
retail basis
the counterfeit adderall contain
methamphetamine
the counterfeit xanax and oxycodone
contain fentanyl
and other dangerous opioids
law enforcement investigators also
discovered that prasad was laundering
his drug proceeds
with the assistance of a local real
estate investor
named benny dennishew the laundered
funds were used to purchase real estate
which in turn was used by the drug
trafficking organization for safe houses
stash houses grow operations and a
hallucinogenic mushroom grow
operation that span three different
states
search warrants were executed yesterday
they resulted in the caesar of
hallucinogenic mushrooms
counterfeit adderall counterfeit xanax
lsd and other drugs
authorities also received over a hundred
or uh seized over a hundred thousand
dollars in cash which is some of which
is in front of you
firearms and a number of ballistic
a vests of these items are here in front
of you today
but they represent a very small fraction
of the dangerous drugs that were peddled
in our community
and a very small fraction of the illegal
proceeds
from drug trafficking in fact
investigators estimate that the overall
sales of the illegal drugs sold by this
organization
exceed one million dollars what is
particularly disturbing about this case
is the fact that what appeared to be
extremely well educated and talented
people
who had many opportunities in life to
choose from
instead focus their business acumen and
education
on dealing illegal dangerous and
counterfeit drugs
and they sold much of this often
camouflage poison
to our unsuspecting students and other
individuals in our community
today's indictment demonstrates that
they went into the wrong business
now they face between 10 years to life
in federal prison
we are currently prosecuting a related
case as well
in that case investigators discovered
that former university of texas san
antonio professor
rose rodriguez ravine supplied
prasad with counterfeit adderall laced
with meth
on numerous occasions her co-defendant
brandon sims
distributed counterfeit adderall pills
to utsa
students and others along with ravine
these defendants used a consumer app
similar to doordash to market and sell
counterfeit and other illicit drugs
ignoring the widespread sale and abuse
of these substances
is not the answer we need to educate our
communities about the dangers inherent
in counterfeit drugs people should know
that when you buy a pill and take a pill
from someone on the street you have no
idea what you're putting into your body
and you can become
addicted to a dangerous drug or
worse die from an overdose
it's important to remember that the
charges described today are allegations
these defendants are presumed innocent
until proven
guilty in federal court
i want to thank the austin tactical
diversion squad
whose work resulted in today's
announcement a task force which includes
the dea
irs criminal investigations fbi
the austin police department the lakeway
police department
the cedar park police department the
texas national guard and the travis
county sheriff's
i want to thank them for their tireless
efforts to protect our community
and bring these defendants to justice i
also want to express my appreciation to
the individuals standing behind me today
who are leaders in the law enforcement
community and represent
some of these agencies
finally i want to thank law enforcement
in general
these days our police are too often
vilified defunded
and attacked this case shows
that without robust and effective law
enforcement
our society is simply less safe
at this time i'm going to turn the
podium over to sac whipple
from the dea to say a few words
thank you attorney sopher my name is
steve
i'm the special agent charge for dea
here the houston division which covers
the austin
austin region yesterday's takedown
is is the product of a lot of hard work
by
by the agencies that you see standing up
here this this case
this investigation was started by the
austin police department by
a detective uh that brought this case to
our tactical diversion squad
and was the lead investigator for for
this
very complex long-term investigation
so my hat's off to the austin police
department for bringing this case
and for or for helping helping us pursue
it to its to its fullest completion
um mr silver talked about a lot of the
issues that we saw in this case
it's it's an internet it's a it's it's a
multi-state
investigation it's complex um
these kids um they're all well educated
um
we saw eight current or former ut
students
that were members of this organization
we saw mathematics majors chemistry
majors a psychology major business major
majors
and they decided to turn their talents
into this illicit operation
they were pretty sophisticated about how
they did it they
used social media group me is a real
common uh platform that they used
uh to arrange the sales of the the
narcotics sales happen both on
on campus as well as off campus
they used venmo um zell
paypal other other apps as well as cash
for for handling their cash um we have a
fairly complicated money laundering
scheme
and so as you can see there's multitude
of crimes that happened along the way in
this investigation
and it's only because of our task force
environment having the fbi having irs
having austin pd
lakeway uh uh pd having
these components in our task force and
the expertise and the resources that
each of these departments bring
enable us to do these kind of cases
the point that we really would like
people to take away from this
investigation
is when you send your kids to college
and they think they're buying a
prescription pill adderall
to get them through a finals exam
chances are
high chances are that it's not it's not
adderall it's methamphetamine
uh they're by xanax uh they think
um it's it's manufactured to look like
xanax but it's gonna be
it's gonna be fentanyl and parents are
seeing their kids come home from college
messed up and they they don't understand
why
the kids said mom i took an adderall
turns out it was methamphetamines highly
addictive
fentanyl highly deadly as
mr sofer mentioned we had two defendants
die of overdose
in the middle of this investigation who
would be in jail today had they
not overdosed and died
so our message is if you buy it on the
street
it's not going to be pharmaceutical this
organization did
sell some diverted pharmaceutical uh
narcotics
but they couldn't get enough and so they
they went to the manufacturing route
like professor rabine and what she was
providing that was all methamphetamines
that were it was killed out and with a
clandestine pill press
and put out on the street as as adderall
interesting other part that we saw is a
large amount of
lsd and psilocybin we
we eraded and are seizing a psilocybin
grow and processing facility
outside of dripping springs it was quite
a complex operation we took about 33
kilos
worth of psilocybin yesterday
and that was just a small piece they had
a they had a ventilation problem and
they lost about two-thirds or
three-quarters of their crop what we
understand
and so they had to destroy a bunch right
before uh
we showed up so this is
this is making it to our college
campuses it's not just here at ut
or utsa this is a problem that we see in
every college campus across the nation
um and we're just asking that parents
and students
pay attention to what you do don't buy
this stuff on the street because
you're not buying what you think you are
with that i'm going to turn this over to
richard doss who is the
special agent in charge for the internal
revenue service
all right thank you i'd like to thank
everybody here also uh
and i thank all the work that the law
enforcement partners have done in this
and uh so good morning everybody my name
is rick goss
i'm the special agent in charge for irs
criminal investigations houston division
which we cover austin and all of western
texas
i'd like to start by saying that
yesterday's arrests marked a
serious victory in the austin area and
for the people who lived there
i just wanted to take a second to
explain irs's mission uh
irs criminal investigations mission in
the narcotics investigation
arena so the role of irs
criminal investigation is simply to
follow the money wherever it goes
and to identify the ringleaders
and facilitators of those organizations
and
to disrupt the illicit financial gains
that are the lifeblood of those
organizations and our
our agents remain committed to our
mission of dismantling
narcotics trafficking organizations and
and putting the those people that run
those organizations
in jail where they belong and with that
i just want to turn it over to chief
radford
for a few more comments thank you thanks
sir
good morning ladies and gentlemen i'm
todd radford chief of police of the city
lakeway i'm currently the president of
the central texas chiefs association as
well
i i wanna i was honored to get the phone
call to be able to
come here today and represent local law
enforcement both the austin police
department
cedar park travis county sheriff's
office and obviously ourselves
as we all have officers that are engaged
in this and other types of
investigations like this but to be part
of this task force
to stand with our federal partners and
our state partners county and local
partners
in a time when we challenge
we are challenged in law enforcement if
if reform is necessary i think this is a
great example what that looks like for
us
we come together with one vision one
mission and that's to take the bad guys
off the street
and to make our communities safer and i
think this case shows exactly what that
looks like
so i'm very proud and honored to
represent not only the city of lakeway
but local law enforcement as we stand
along our federal partners
to say to you today that this case is
just one of a small number of cases
that makes our communities safer thank
you and that you'd be blessed in your
holiday season
i'll now turn it back over to the city
u.s attorney
so we have time for some questions
anybody have a question
so we're not going to get into the
details of all that now some of this is
still under investigation i'll just tell
you that two of the
people who likely would have been
defendants in this case didn't make it
that far
because they overdosed on these kind of
drugs
yesterday were they owned
or were they all in west campus i'm
going to turn that over to uh mark
marshall who's a assistant united states
attorney who's prosecuting the case
we ran warrants and west campus in two
separate locations
uh off campus but in the 24th street
45th street area
here in austin another one down south a
little bit
the psilocybin grow was out off of
circle drive and thomas springs road
in the oak hill area we ran another
warmth in portland oregon where we got a
full marijuana grow
connected to this particular
organization that's where the warrants
were primarily run
no we did not run anything on campus
most of the activity was the west campus
area some of the sales occurred on
campus
but none of the particular warrants were
run on campus
i can't get into the specifics of the
investigation at this point a lot of
that is still sealed
well the quantity up front we had a
pretty good idea the first investigation
and first enforcement action we took in
2019
involved 14 kilos of prezlam tablets
that's 22 pounds
that's a lot so we had a good idea that
we were engaged in
that kind of organization the psilocybin
growth surprised me
it's the biggest girl i've seen
all the psilocybin came from these guys
in the grove
as as the u.s attorney indicated rose
rabin
was arrested in san antonio she was one
of the suppliers producing adderall
tablets
that's all public record i think they
ran stories on that town in san antonio
about 21 kilos of meth
and and tablets uh the regulation and i
cannot comment on that
austin police department got information
on one of the targets
and that's how it started back in 2019.
i can't comment on that specific
activity there was an enforcement action
that involved the search warrant and
that's where we got the initial 14 kilos
of adderall
[Music]
well two guys died uh i'm not sure of
their connection with ut right now and i
couldn't comment on it anyway
uh some of the people were talking about
maybe witnesses and i can't identify
them at this point
no within the last six months
yes they were all engaged in activity in
those particular areas and we were doing
activities out there but i can't comment
on those specific activities a lot of it
is still sealed
i don't have the specific numbers but if
you go back to march of 2020 i think the
williamson county medical examiner among
others had a press conference and talked
about
their observation of increased overdoses
in and around the austin
area including williamson and travis
counties
somewhere somewhere
but some of this stuff
you're absolutely correct um and that's
the whole marketing ploy
uh with these what we call counterfeit
pharmaceuticals
people think they're taking medicine
something that a doctor has
prescribed that a pharmaceutical
manufacturer has made
and a pharmacist has dispensed this
none of this is that this has been was
has been made in somebody's
garage with a clandestine pill press
and with inexact uh measurements that's
why you'll see somebody take
take uh what they think is a xanax and
overdose and die
because it's fentanyl or maybe even
worse car fentanyl
but it's being marketed to these people
to kids to anybody who's going to buy it
on the street
as a pharmaceutical
our our office of diversion expends
a great deal of resources to try to
control uh
the diversion of legitimate
pharmaceuticals it's a closed system
we're supposed to be able to track a
pill from when it's manufactured to
to when it's been dispensed to a patient
um
so we expend a lot of effort in
preventing that diversion outside of
that closed circle
um and as a result we see
we see this kind of happen where it's
clandestinely manufactured
and marketed as legitimate
pharmaceuticals
um actually yes to both um
it leaves a trail and um it does
complicate things i mean
any steps that you take the thor being
found out to do something
complicates our job uh it makes us get
smarter about
uh the applications and and how to work
them
um it is it is a tool of efficiency
uh for like this organization and using
group me and and and
zell and these other uh other apps
um it's a lot safer to get you know
sell me your money versus hand me you
know 200 bucks and i got in my pocket
and i get hit on the head and
be robbed so there's it
there's efficiencies for them
efficiencies for us as well as
complications for us
i'm i have to take i haven't taken a
look at those what which ones they are
yeah those were little bites candies oh
those are the cant well the thc edibles
thc animals
there's almost like a drugstore you know
all kinds of different i mean
we saw actual cocaine we saw actual math
uh the vast majority of what's being
sold those are the pharmaceuticals and
then
and they had recently moved into into
the lsd
and and the psilocybin uh because of you
know some overdose deaths and things
like that
i i use that term it's like it's like a
storefront it's like a drugstore they
had all kinds of stuff for sale
well there are multiple locations um you
know everything from the uh
yeah like the apartments uh uh uh that
where they lived
they they sold out of they stashed as
well uh the the operation down in
the psilocybin grow in manufacturing uh
they
there's a lot of science in that and
there was a lot of effort and thought
and money invested into that
process and because you have to really
control the environment because if you
get outside
spores or whatever it can kill the uh
the grow i mean so there's
it was pretty complicated now a lot of
them what they lived in
is pretty nasty you know but uh but that
particular manufacturing facility for
for the
for the mushrooms uh they they had to
control the environment uh
[Music]
temperatures
so yes there's more to do here there's
more to do in san antonio
houston all of our college campuses yes
um
i am that's why we're hoping this
message resonates at home with parents
with students um and we're going to
continue these investigations you
everybody
appreciate it
just
you